les étoiles du pont du bateau la
première étoile est décernée à celui qui
défonce tous les animateurs alors que
dans sa vie son seul prime c'est ouf
c'est mathieu de l'emploi ensuite
deuxième étoile à la deuxième étoile
c'est l'étoile de l'étoile à ckoi parce
que comme une étoile elle brille et
comme une étoile l'ami lancé isabelle
morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
bnp
mdp
je sais qu'elle est belle celle ci la
fin sur la photo du chicot pas à dieu
bénisse la photo mais est ce toi tu
change pas ça fait dix ans que je te
connais tu es de plus en plus belle
consigne a reçu merci excuse moi ta main
jusqu'aux la csn s'est pas de l'humour a
plus toute sa tête
troisième étoile c'est l'étoile de celui
qui est pas le meilleur mais comme ce
n'était pas le plus cher ça nous arrange
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
ensuite étoiles du chroniqueur tellement
passionné de magie qui l'a fait
disparaître sa dignité maxime guen
[Applaudissements]
je fais
ça fait plaisir pour le plaisir prendre
le temps de temps en temps c'est bien ce
à quoi ça confirme ça me fait plaisir le
plaisir est prévue quoi pour 2019
2010neuf l'année dix neuf ans ben
justement
prévoyez que d'être libre beaucoup de
plages de libre et pas des supporter une
autre étoile étoiles à étoile du
chroniqueur qui collectionne les mst
comme on et collectionne les images
panini et jean-michel mer rouge entendu
m estime que 4 cette année je vous fais
mais il est la brillante sur n'est que
4e il est con on ad'autres prochaine
étoiles et toiles la chroniqueuse qui
est la dernière arrivée dans l'équipe et
du coup qui sera la prochaine à repartir
gesca anthony
c'est
[Applaudissements]
là la prochaine était évidente c'est
l'étoile du chroniqueur dont on ne dira
jamais ces nouveaux michel drucker c'est
gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
une autre étoile étoiles de j'ai bossé
au csa et maintenant atp mais finalement
c'est le même tarif payé regarder la
télé christine kelly l'étoile de la miss
france préférait de cyril delphine
wespiser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que ça change et des peep qui
a dit ça je les ai entendus je les ai
vus à tahiti ça n'a rien voulu me le
disent les yeux dans les yeux marche
anthony n'ont pas réfléchi deux jours
qu'est ce qu'il en est je vais te dire
mais je vous le dis aujourd'hui que sa
part qu'on peut pas mettre tout le temps
d'atteindre dans cette émission non plus
je vais je vais te dire il ya miss
tahiti
je vais te dire alors je vais te dire la
vérité moi tout ça j'aime beaucoup les
jeunes filles j'aime en coulant autour
du bureau c'est que vous avez menti
j'aime beaucoup la gente féminine
parce que je la respecte mais je vais
vous dire vous vous êtes bien sûr très
jolie elle est très jolie mais aucune
des données monde et liam en délire
voilà je préfère le dire comme ça c'est
clair ce fait de la réponse comme moi
mais parce qu'on n'est pas satisfait la
elle vous a demandé de la réponse j'ai
même twitté comme quoi vous étiez
toujours à miss préférée non mais je
savais qu'un mauvais compte en fait il a
fini avec un mauvais chez moi est un
vrai compte chez elle pour que ça
n'arrive pas nos oreilles moi j'ai un
pote qui me dit henri iv il a twitté sur
toile soit tous sur ta et du coup là où
que je voulais la la réponse fuse et moi
on est venu pour faire une émission est
de regrouper chaud ici le postulat de
départ si on vient on est en train de
chine et des maintes fois la fois
delphine tu sais que je t'adore tu es
toujours ma préférée voilà roger n'est
pas venu aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui du
coup et la foule ouais je sais gré c'est
un rôle important à mettre les choses au
clair que la vérité soit faite c'est
vrai je rappelle combien de retirer
l'antenne de sa télé a rougi et bien sûr
mais bien sûr je te le répète tu n'es
pas mon délire non mais c'est normal
mais je te trouve magnifique voilà
d'autres shows des skins wayne on touche
bientôt la fin l étoile de la miss
france étoiles de la miss maisons alfort
préféré de cyrine valérie bénard
charest vous êtes ma miss préférée à ces
chantiers pourtant vous n'êtes pas mon
délire mais si votre soeur pas pareil
ah oui oui bah on me fait vous quand
même [ __ ] non je termine juste avec une
étoile un peu spécial c'est une étoile à
remettre pour une personne du public
c'est kelly b d'aullène
[Applaudissements]
alors eh ben merci pour ces et j'en suis
je dans son travail